[Music]
we're gonna start this hour with baton
rouge brett is with us hi brett how are
you
hey dave how are you better than i
deserve what's up
great got a question here uh
dealing with a little emotional i guess
sale of possibly some equities that my
father had
given me when he passed away about four
or five years ago
owe about 108
000 on the house have a 15-year mortgage
just refinanced about a year ago so i
guess 14 left
and we've had some pretty tremendous
gains in the stock since i inherited it
a little over
probably a million in gains and i guess
he never sold it i grew up
we never sold it collected the dividends
and now it's finally reached a point
where i think
it's in my best option to sell just a
piece of it to pay the last piece of
debt off
and i guess i just needed some
reassurance because i have never once
thought about selling you
okay
well the the total investment account of
equities is worth what
1.6 million
and 180 000 pays off your house
yes
okay
so
i mean
like 10 percent
it's like none of it
you're barely touching it
that's very true and i guess that was
the emotional part of it it was given to
me
and you know i guess watching him he
just collected dividends he just held it
held it and i feel like holding it for
these past four years has been a
tremendous gain but
telling a piece of it i guess that's it
you you somewhat answered it for me
right there it's a small piece and now
here's the other thing what this does
bring up though
is it does need it brings up
you know what your father did
with these stocks
was
you have to decide
was that his
unwritten unsaid instruction that you
should follow no matter what happens
or was it good for him at the time
but he would expect you to think on your
own
into the future as to whether that's
still a good strategy
which is i'm i'm guessing number two
would be the thing
because right it'd be pretty weird for
him to look at you and go never sell
these stocks
i mean that would be something someone
would say about the family farm
or about the family bible or about your
great great great great grandfather's
musket you know or something like that
never sell that wouldn't make sense but
never sell stocks
really no i don't think he said that did
he
no no sir not at all so you're not
besmirching his legacy
his intent he's not in heaven frowning
at you if you sold them all
and diversified and put them into
something else that you believed to be a
better investment with good critical
thinking skills
very
yes 100 i agree with you so i i think
you kind of got to get that going
because
the the bulk of my conversation with you
before i started of your explanation to
me was all about what grandpa um or what
papa always did and
it's worked for me
uh but i want you to be independent in
your thinking of
his memory we can honor his memory best
by continuing to do good critical
thinking thought into the future this is
not a
a family heirloom it's stocks
correct yes sir
so yeah in other words if you feel like
that these things have run their course
and you've had a good run but you don't
really like the future
it'd be okay to liquidate the whole
stinking thing and put it in mutual
funds and pay off your house that'd be
okay with me that'd be my tendency by
the way
because i don't play single stocks
i don't like the risk too much risk for
me
but uh but i you you have to work
through the emotional part of it and go
okay what were dad's wishes here what
was his wishes what did he want you to
do and so what i want my kids to do is
live on principle
after i'm gone
by by principle i mean um a series of
principles that give them good critical
thinking skills good spiritual eyes on
the world
uh those kinds of things and and then
given all of that they can make a lot of
decisions that were different than the
old man made but one of our principles
would be we don't borrow money now that
one i would expect them to hold too
you know one of our principles would be
we're always generous i would expect
them to hold to that principle
but you know the nuance and the tactical
of exactly how you do some of those
things i i want to leave them free to
make judgments because the world does
change good question that's a very good
call